Harry and Megan are still senior Royals
for now that all ends on March 31st when
they step away from their roles the two
are expected to return to the UK in June
for the Queen's official birthday
celebration and they're going to lose a
huge perk no more royal carriage rides
now in the past Harry and Megan have
ridden in a horse and carriage as part
of the parade they won't be doing that
anymore because they are no longer
senior working members of the royal
family but they will appear on the
balcony at buckingham palace and their
position on the balcony won't change
Harry's place in line to the throne
remains number 6 so will expect to see
them in their usual spot on the balcony
Megan sure didn't seem too upset about
her future during a private visit to
Britain's National Theatre showing she
can be thrifty she wore a 55 dollar
blouse from Topshop meanwhile today
Harry also made a solo trip to a race
car exhibition it's very nice to be back
last night at the endeavour fund Awards
just check out Megan and Harry's faces
when military vet Danny Holland proposed
to his longtime girlfriend Lauren price
a royal source reports that the royal
family is disappointed they will not see
Archie during this trip while maybe
Harry and Megan will share some new
pictures of their son when they come
face-to-face with the Queen and the
other Royals at the annual Commonwealth
Day service on Monday after that it's
wheels up the Commonwealth Day service
will take part earlier in the day so I
think Harry and Megan hope to be on a
plane that evening so they can rush back
to their little chat
[Music]